summer is officially here many mountain
communities are getting some unwanted
visitors hungry bears in search of food
now a group of grizzly bears near
Yellowstone National Park is testing
outdoor products like trash cans and
coolers to see if they are truly bear
resistant Carter Evans shows us it's an
effort to keep bears away from humans
and keep them in the wild when it comes
to grizzly versus garbage can most are
no match and these particular bears are
some of the best in the business at
tearing things apart are some better
product testers than others very much so
Randy Gravette helps tempt bears to
break into containers at the nonprofit
grizzly and wolf Discovery Center just
outside Yellowstone National Park when
bears get into unnatural food sources
it's bad for bears and it's bad for
people the eight resident Grizzlies were
brought here because like these bears
they got too comfortable foraging for
human food once they have even maybe
just one interaction where they decide
that a food was easy and seemed safe
then they're going to go back to that
food source problem bears are often
euthanized or relocated here they're
unnatural skills are put to work this
grizzly named spirit just loves to crack
open coolers while 600-pound quorum uses
the tried-and-true CPR method to pop a
garbage can for about 500 bucks
companies can find out if their
containers can stand the test to the
delight of those who come to bear
witness
he just kept managing to move that thing
around until he just cracked it right
open and now you know which cooler you
might bring with you I got the white one
products that survive a 60-minute
mauling can be sold as bear resistant
but not all are successful this doesn't
look so good no no you can see all the
styrofoam so they were able to literally
tear that apart even this steel trash
Locker was no match they just ripped the
hinges right up to hinges right off when
you first started only ten percent of
the containers we're passing the bear
test and now it's around 65
the manufacturers are getting it figured
out the ultimate goal is to benefit the
Bears out in the wild
saving bears one cooler at a time for
CBS this morning Carter Evans
Yellowstone why am i in favor the Bears
you invite yourselves rooting for them
right do find yourself reading from but
I like that lay I'm going to take the
white one bear can't get into that one
that's that's great piece